Why did Dumbledore groom Harry to die? How
could they trust student safety to a werewolf?
And is Slytherin's hatred and distrust of the
other houses justified? Keep watching to find out!
Former Death Eater or not, seeking out a job
working with children to procure the power you
never had as a kid isn't a cute or defensible
move. Fans tend to give Severus Snape a pass on
his questionable behavior as a teacher because
he turns on Voldemort to become a double agent
for Dumbledore. Yet his motives to betray
Voldemort have little to do with nobility.
Snape was angry that Voldemort killed Lily, but
he was all too happy to let James and Harry die
to snag the one that got away for himself
— that's not love. And just because he
saves Harry's life a few times doesn't excuse
bullying a child because he looks like his dad.
And it's not just Harry that Snape lords over
like a classroom bully who's still reliving his
glory days. Neville's boggart proves that
he's more afraid of Snape than the woman
who tortured his parents into insanity
— which is horrifying, to say the least.
Despite the fandom's romanticization
of Snape, his few heroic moments and
his obsession over a woman who told him "no"
don't erase his cruelty toward his students.
You'd be hard-pressed to find a "Harry
Potter" fan who doesn't love Rubeus Hagrid,
but that doesn't mean that he's without his
faults. Hagrid's love for magical creatures
may be legendary, but he doesn't always put
their needs ahead of his own selfishness.
Should Hagrid be keeping a dragon as a pet or
chaining up a three-headed dog in a tiny room
to protect a treasure? Absolutely not. In fact,
Hagrid's love for creatures endlessly puts their
lives at risk — and the lives of his students.
Whether he's risking the life of Aragog,
the arachnid he saved, by smuggling him
in the castle when he's a Hogwarts student, or
bringing a hippogriff to his unruly classroom,
quite a few animals would have been better off
not knowing him. Buckbeak nearly dies because
of Hagrid's negligence when Buckbeak
was just doing what's in its nature.
Between that and drinking copious
amounts of alcohol around students,
our favorite half-giant isn't so cuddly after all.
By Dumbledore's estimations, Sybill Trelawney
has made precisely two real predictions during
her tenure at Hogwarts: The prophecy
regarding Voldemort's vanquisher and
the "Prisoner of Azkaban" prophecy where
she predicts the return of Peter Pettigrew.
"He who betrayed his friends at
Hogwarts with murder shall break free!
Innocent blood shall be spilt!"
Given that Trelawney doesn't even
remember her actual predictions,
she's either an intentional fraud who likes
to toy with her students for dramatic effect,
or she's convinced herself to
believe her own mind games.
Either way, she treats her students
like pawns in a metaphysical experiment.
And she also emotionally abuses Hermione just
because she's a bit of a know-it-all. Calling a
student's soul as dry as a book is pretty gross.
If your student questions the legitimacy of your
subject, you don't lash out and eviscerate their
self-confidence — they're children. Be an adult.
Sure, Remus Lupin [REE-muss LOO-pin] is
hands-down the school's most competent
Defense Against the Dark Arts teacher that we
see throughout the series, but why is he left
to howl at the moon on Hogwarts grounds at all?
Having the guy hide in a tree during full moons
when he turns into a werewolf in a castle full
of students is questionable judgment at best.
Lupin's wolfy characteristics
certainly aren't his fault,
but for a couple of days out of the month, he
shouldn't be anywhere near students — especially
not when the ever-vindictive Snape is in charge of
his symptom-relieving potion. During transitions,
he should be in a safe, secluded space to
protect himself and everyone around him.
Instead, both he and Dumbledore
leave things to fate,
and Harry and his friends almost die for
it. Lupin's situation is quite tragic,
given how little control he has over his own
body, but that doesn't excuse him from bearing the
responsibility of ensuring his students' safety
before he turns each month and loses all will.
The bar is pretty low for Hogwarts professors,
but even educators like Slughorn leave a lot
to be desired. Sure, Slughorn is competent
when you measure him against the dude who
wears Voldemort as a fashionable headpiece, but
on his own, Slughorn's a pretty awful teacher.
Slughorn uses his students to feed
his narcissism, taking credit for
their accomplishments and displaying them in his
classroom like trophies that he personally won.
He even creates a creepy elite
club for his star students.
Okay, we get it, Hogwarts' terrible safety track
record makes open positions difficult to fill,
but you can't just hire terrible people
because you can't fill a position.
Even Slughorn himself doesn't want to
take the job. Someone really needs to
assist Dumbledore on the hiring process
because his track record is pretty bad.
Albus Dumbledore made an alarming number of
mistakes and oversights during his time at
Hogwarts. Still, none are quite as sinister as
what he does to the wizarding world's golden
boy Harry Potter. In his calculated quest
to defeat Voldemort, Dumbledore raises Harry
to be a martyr for the slaughter, while
never being completely honest with him,
putting Harry in grave danger annually for
reasons the boy never fully understands.
Harry risks his life time and time again to fix
the mistakes of the negligent Hogwarts staff,
yet even when Dumbledore takes
him on perilous Horcrux missions,
Dumbledore still keeps the young wizard in
the dark. Probably because his master plan
requires Harry to die at the right time
in order to destroy the last Horcrux.
It's frankly a shock that Harry even lives long
enough to carry out that insane plan, but the fact
that Dumbledore secretly maneuvers Harry into
sacrificing himself is also pretty shocking.
Despite the fact that Voldemort cursed the
Defense Against the Dark Arts position,
Dumbledore still does little to no vetting when he
fills the open position. Instead, he continually
hires incompetent or straight-up evil wizards
to teach the school's most important subject.
As it stands, we've got professors dying,
some acting as Voldemort's right-hand face,
and a narcissist who obliviates iconic wizards
to steal their life story — just to name a few.
It's wild that Dumbledore is supposed
to be the greatest wizard in his time,
yet he can't be bothered to lift a curse
or come up with a clever way around it.
Hell, Cedric Diggory would still be alive
if Dumbledore instilled some anti-polyjuice
potion measures to prevent identity theft in a
magic school. Use your big brain, Dumbledore!
Apparently, the Forbidden Forest
is only forbidden when professors
aren't hosting detention there. In "The
Sorcerer's Stone," Harry, Ron, and Hermione
get caught out of bed when Malfoy snitches on
them. Genius that he is, he gets lumped into
the detention crew himself by tattling. Instead
of doing something normal like writing lines,
the four students get separated into groups to
hunt down a unicorn killer in a cursed forest.
What the heck are these teachers thinking?!
The forest isn't the only esoteric
punishment at the castle, though.
Filch reminisces about the good old days when
he got to hang students up in the dungeons.
And there's also Dolores Umbridge, who
enjoys making students write lines that
get carved into their skin with a sick
quill. A charming slate of staff, huh?
With the level of House favoritism Hogwarts
professors exhibit when they award or detract
points for the House Cup, the tradition is all
but rigged. A few professors like McGonagall
seem to keep things fair, but even she
shows her Gryffindor cards on occasion.
Snape is less than subtle about his determination
to detract every possible point from Gryffindor
while awarding Slytherin points whenever
he can — and he's not the only one.
"Are you incapable of restraining yourself,
or do you take pride in being
an insufferable know-it-all?"
"He's got a point, you know?"
"Five points from Gryffindor."
However, Dumbledore gets the award for the
worst case of points tampering we've ever seen.
It's bad enough when professors dole
out unfair points throughout the year,
but Dumbledore needs to make a whole dramatic show
of things. In "Sorcerer's Stone," Gryffindors are
dead last until Dumbledore baits and switches the
celebrating Slytherins by publicly awarding Harry
a bunch of points for straight-up murdering
Quirrell, Ron for playing a great game of
overdramatic chess, Hermione for being a cool
witch, and Neville for standing up to his friends.
Of course, he does this after announcing Slytherin
as the winner. No wonder Slytherins are always
so pissy - the headmaster of the school
literally pits every house against them!
"Gryffindor wins the House Cup!"
In the Hogwarts professors' quest to put their
students in as much peril as wizardly possible,
they put on a dangerous and occasionally deadly
international tournament between teenaged martyrs.
Despite the original Triwizard Tournament's
demise due to the death of teenagers,
the wizard schools decide that
this is a swell time to bring
the tradition back in "Goblet of Fire."
It might as well be "The Hunger Games!"
Based on what we know, it doesn't seem like the
professors or headmasters do a single thing to
make it safer this go-around — and what do you
know? Cedric Diggory pays the price with his life.
Sure, having three international schools
compete in a tournament to learn about
different cultures and gain new experiences is
a great idea. However, there doesn't need to be
a death component, with dragons and other
dangerously unpredictable tasks to do so.
The tournament also leads to Dumbledore's
most out-of-character moment in the film
"Harry, Did you put your
name in the Goblet of Fire?!"
"No sir!"
"Did you ask one of the
older students to do it for you?"
"No sir!"
"You're absolutely sure?"
Despite his outrage in the movie, in
the books Dumbledore already knows
that Harry isn't advanced enough to fool
the Goblet's age barrier. Suffice to say,
it's not one of Dumbledore's best moments from the
films, and the tournament is just as deadly as it
was in years past because the professors
couldn't keep a tighter watch on things.
With a headmaster as experienced as Dumbledore,
you'd think that he'd be more than willing to
take the lead on any investigative work when
all is not well at Hogwarts. Yet no matter
how many times Harry, Ron, and Hermione
bring serious situations to the school’s
attention, they brush it off. In the end,
the educators always leave a bunch of kids to do
the dirty work of Hogwarts' negligent professors.
The Hogwarts teachers openly let their students
fight their battles while rarely lifting a
finger to handle situations themselves. Why?
Because of their ego trip, of course. If they
haven't noticed anything themselves, how
on earth could something possibly be funky?
One time would be more than enough, but even
Hogwarts' best professors like McGonagall
gaslight students about any serious concerns
without ever doing anything substantial. When
it comes to the final battle, the students are
somehow still taking charge when many of the
remaining professors don't do all that much
to help out. Just look at the death toll of
students compared to professors. There are far
too many crises at the school to begin with,
but why is there rarely a professor around
when shady wizard drama is going down?
The professors continually say that Hogwarts is
the safest place in the wizarding world — but
that assumption is precisely what causes
them to frequently put students' lives
in danger by being complacent. Hiding
a three-headed dog and the Sorcerer's
Stone in the castle was a major lack of
judgment - and it was just one of many.
Sirius Black manages to infiltrate the
school, Peter Pettigrew runs around as
the Weasleys' rat for years, and Death Eaters
can stroll in whenever they want. If an old
map that a bunch of mischievous kids created
can detect someone who's supposed to be dead,
why aren't more measures like
that taken by actual professors?
For an impenetrable school, a whole lot
of devious wizards manage to infiltrate.
How is this a safe school,
and why aren't the professors and its headmaster
taking these breaches in security seriously?
How many students have to die before professors
stop toting the "there's no safer place" tagline
and actually pay attention to what's happening
around them? If Harry Potter — the world's most
oblivious wizard — notices a problem when the
teachers don't, that's definitely a red flag.
Even the repetition of tragic historical events
goes unbothered by the staff. At the first sign
of the Chamber's reopening, the school should be
evacuated — let alone after multiple petrified
students are discovered. One wrong glance, and the
school would have a dozen more Moaning Myrtles.
It's a miracle it takes so long before
parents start pulling their kids from school.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.